non pas encore ce foutu ce juste un
tournoi a promis merci pour cette super
soirée
[Musique]
anna anna
salut mathiot époux soit bien ok suite
aux instructions sur ce téléphone un
paquet se trouve dans ce gilet en fils
si tu ne le livre pas tant anas radieux
nous te surveille on obéit et analysera
c'est bien combat éclate toi bien roll
train
en contact de tatort attendez attendez
on vient de braquer en pointe sur moi
pour ce foutu paquet
mathiot c'est la vie
tu as i minier
bon ça vient je vais dévoiler
des vestes ou quoi
c'est quoi cet endroit c'est une blague
ou et ex
tout ça n'est qu'un jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on doit partir
où est elle
cours